(audience cheering)
I feel like I am the envy of the room.
Please welcome Sam Heughan.
Oh, thank you. Hi.
(audience cheering wildly)
Nice to see you.
It's so nice to see you.
I just drooled.
Something.
It's all right.
I'm drooling as well.
Okay, good.
I'm like, I just drooled, there goes my cool.
(Sam chuckling)
I blow it every time.
It's a better place to just start from reality
Right? Yeah. Yeah. Sure.
The base reality. I drool.
Basic droolers, yeah.
Well, get to know me.
Right?
Yes.
Actually, there are people who already know you
in the audience.
Oh.
We have some Heughligans here.
You do? Where?
Yes.
(audience cheering)
Oh, look.
I mean, how fun, how crazy?
It's so nice.
And it's so nice to have the fans here
and we've had this huge droughtlander.
It's been, you know, almost--
Droughtlander?
Droughtlander. And now we're finally back on,
so we're--
Maybe you need a Drewlander.
A Drew...
(audience clapping)
Yeah. I like it.
Okay. It is design week on the show.
We are talking all things design.
Oh right. Okay.
Do you have any design loves or dislikes?
Any design loves or dislikes?
I recently moved house actually in Scotland
and I have this old tavern that has been done up.
And so I love it. It's very--
Do you live in an old tavern?
I do, which is probably quite fitting for me,
to be honest.
I did a deep dive on your Instagram.
Oh.
and you are all about the spirits.
Yeah.
Pun intended.
Yes, not the ghosts but the--
No. The imbibable ones.
The imbibable ones.
Yes, I have a whiskey brand
and we recently released a tequila as well so, yeah.
(audience whooping)
And,
you are everywhere with your best friend
and in kilts, and I heard you love a kilt.
I do.
I have to ask you, do you wear it traditionally?
Oh, what do you mean by that?
You know.
(audience laughing)
It's a little breezy,
Yeah.
I heard that's the traditional way to wear a kilt.
It is. It is absolutely true.
Alfresco.
Alfresco, it's liberating.
Riding a horse in a kilt can be interesting,
but no, it's great.
I've just come back from New Zealand.
I've been shooting my travel show "Men In Kilts"
and my good friend, Graham McTavish,
we do obviously wear kilts while exploring New Zealand.
And do you wear them traditionally?
And we may do. Yes.
(Drew shrieking)
(audience cheering)
I'm in a skirt right now and I cannot imagine.
And are you tradition, I don't even know.
I don't even know why I'm asking you this.
(everybody laughing)
But you can.
I can? I'm allowed to?
I'm wearing underwear.
Oh, you're crazy. What's wrong with you?
I don't know.
Yeah,
you're doing it all wrong.
I'm starting to rethink it.
Yeah, you should.
I have two daughters though.
I would literally not allow them to ever wear a skirt
with no underwear.
So I guess that's the problem.
Well, see, the kilt is very heavy material, okay?
And there's a lot of fabric there.
There's still a giant open vent.
I mean, what happens?
Okay.
(Drew giggling)
What happens if you fall?
And I don't know either that or just,
Yeah. Yeah.
I mean,
when I fall, it's like, I eat it.
I roll, you know.
Well, actually the Scots, they used to go into battle
and they would, they would take their kilts off
and sometimes just run into battle just in their shirts.
Just to scare the opposition,
(audience laughing)
or to thrill the opposition. I dunno.
How do you, yeah.
How does one keep in battle if you're like,
I would--
Just completely nude?
Yeah. I'm not sure.
I haven't tried that one, Drew, but I might in the future.
There's a common theme here.
I'm beginning to see here right now, yeah.
(upbeat music)